ouch gum - fair - back
welcome to we're playing the Stanley
parable inside the sound a parable
inside a satellite power ball inside I
could go on forever literally I can't
what
okay I guess the full game just came out
today can't wait to try it I'm feeling a
little bit afternoon drowsy so I did I
feel like this game is just gonna like
take advantage of me kind of that's the
kind of mind [ __ ] we're talking about
here alright let's see I'm I hear it's
great and I'm very excited played and
I'll see if it's as good as the original
mod did the devil story of a man named
Stanley here yeah Stanley work for a
company in a big building where he was
employee number four to seven employee
number four to seven job was simple he
sat at his desk in room four to seven
and he pushed buttons people always came
to him through a monitor on his desk
telling him what buttons to push
how long to push and in what order
this is what employee 47 did every day
every month from every exact factor in
the same others might have considered
its sole king stanley relished every
moment that the orders came in there we
have been made exactly for this job
Stanley was happy and then one day
something very peculiar happened Miley
Cyrus thought it's working ever changed
Stanley something he would never quite
forget he fed his desk for nearly an
hour when he realized that not one
single order had arrived on the monitor
for him to follow no one had showed up
to give him instructions call a meeting
or even say I never in all his years of
the company had this happened this
complete isolation something was very
clearly wrong
shocked frozen solid Stanley found
himself unable to move for the longest
time but as he came to his wits and
regained his senses he got up from his
desk and stepped out of his office
I'm starting to think that there are no
other employees that he's like alright
so start identical so I think it's gonna
play out this kind of the same way a
chair you're not blue are you why you're
not blue you're trying to mindfuck me
here
hi well we're heading out and I don't
like where this good workers were gone
what could it mean Stanley decided to go
to the meeting room perhaps he had
simply missed a memo no matter how hard
Stanley looked he couldn't find a trace
of his coworkers
hello where are you hello phone what are
you doing
what is it Mugsy whoo-hoo farting that's
hilarious
that's the funniest [ __ ] ever oh my god
all right somewhere we have to look for
it so he went around touching every
little didn't make a single difference
no did it a bum I shut on anyway shut
the [ __ ] up I'm going okay what a hell
do you want from me that is a beautiful
mountain what happens if I stare at it
really long jump-scare some [ __ ] but
butthole appears it fades in rice is so
bright outside
ah my eyes huh well I guess what
no oh they don't know they're not the
same are you gonna close on me what is
going on here where am I it is a little
different
the level design it very least I don't
trust what what did I say what am I
supposed to go what is it cop say what
does the cop say be my Valentine all
right I'm fine I had well who doesn't
hate mondays jeez get over it lug all
right we're here I think another jump
scare no not today huh
gosh darn it where is everyone oh here
here it is very okay da came to a set of
two open doors he entered the door on
his left okay
but I don't want to all right I'll lead
you bros decide which one the left one
the left one okay III last time I did
the opposite of what he said and I'm
wrong get pissed so first time we play
this we're gonna take the left one now
what
well [ __ ] were fought god damn it
gosh darn it it's with his [ __ ]
paintings yeah a little bit man cheap as
cheap as people getting the same
paintings what is this what is this
hello tips for not getting fired there
was not a single person here either way
disbelief Stanley decided to go up to
his boss's office hoping he might find
an answer there so true using slides
assure employees that everything is okay
make sure your slide has a slick blue
graphic in the header and throw some
bevel on yeah that's good
this will inch okay everyone is unique
you most of all it's very true don't
forget next slide please number of
slides of his slides slides charts
slides and charts that doesn't even make
any sense
rate at which charts on the same slide
distantly just stood there doing nothing
at all I'm looking at the chart I have
nothing better to do with my time than
to sit around and describe every
fascinating little detail of his
inability to do anything this is why
Stanley and I are such good terms
perfect
okay I better get going I guess I just
want to look around a little bit there's
so much Easter eggs in these push for
funding get Chris out of the broom
closet okay
paper fire paper guy hire someone to
fire the papers who moved my desk please
keep the targets on the topic I want is
blurt out
oh it's tomorrow complete today's
unfinished reflect the future was
yesterday tomorrow okay
all right enough of that meeting room
termination Tuesday what the [ __ ] is I
do not alter without consulting
whiteboard manage hey when people [ __ ]
with your MOT whiteboard all right well
you know what
you can [ __ ] pause if you want to
read the rest how about I enjoy broom
closet where is he
why are you okay sir the broom closet
but there was nothing here actually
turned around and got back on track it
sounds a little different today have
something happen to your voice sir no
I'm not going back well there was
nothing thought it was nothing here no
choice to make no path to follow just an
empty broom closet
sharing reason to still be here hey sure
don't don't patronize me sir I don't
even know what I mean Thunder Sunny's
baffling that Stanley was still just
sitting in the bride
he wasn't even doing anything at least
if there was something to interact with
he'd be justified in some way well it is
he's literally just standing there doing
sweet FA what the [ __ ] is FA and I'm
loving this room they have duct tape and
duct tape are you are you really still
in the broom closet standing around
doing nothing yes funny because I love
me some explanation here I'm genuinely
confused
hey broom there's a broom in here how
about that I love brooms Everett you la
brooms I can you like the broom closet -
I can I can tell you to realize there's
no choice or anything in here right if I
said Stanley walked past the broom
closet and this she would have had a
reason for exploring it to find out now
this is even occur to me because
literally this closet is of absolutely
no significance to the story what so
ever I never would have thought to
mention it well you dead you're dead and
the broom is here and it's a mighty sexy
broom I'll finally be to you this is
somehow its own branching path maybe
maybe when you go talk about this with
your friend you'll say oh did you get
the broom typical YouTube comment right
there I'm just kidding all right um all
right here we are decisions yeah coming
to a staircase Stanley walked upstairs
to his boss's office okay this is where
you can actually go down but it is
funnier to go to the boss office as far
as I concern
so this don't know where the dare it is
okay all right whoa fancy smancy
dancing this executive bathroom boy that
even be there hey Chaz how you died head
here what wait what there's still no
people here I understand why the boss
beer there's no people Wow
like I'm entering into his manager's
office Stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any
in life shocked unraveled Stanley
wondered him under din disbelief
who orchestrated this what dark secret
was being held from him what he could
not have known was at the keypad behind
the boss's desk guarded the terrible
truth truth that his boss had been
keeping from him and so the boss had
assigned it an extra secret pin number
exorcising eight four five executors
fours Stanley couldn't possibly have
known this well someone just [ __ ]
told me how about that I feel like this
is a what's Homer Simpson's boss name I
[ __ ] forgot doesn't it feel like his
office kind of what Stanley just sat
around twiddling his thumbs trying to
input anything on the device was useless
I could never possibly know that the
combination was to eight four five but I
better be right wrong then get
incredibly by simply pushing random
buttons on the keypad
Stanley happen to input the correct code
by sheer luck
hell yeah hazing well stepped into the
newly opened passageway Wow hello spends
a lot of portal in a lot of ways well
what are you what are you doing what is
this what is this place explain to me
what the [ __ ] is going on here with the
figs Guinea II mean II knew many me oh
okay click oh that's the big button
know-it-all never mind
what am i doing what am i doing with my
life
noting noting yeah the mind of mine
[ __ ] this one is not that bad bag I'm
surprised descending deeper into the
building
Stanley realized he felt a bit peculiar
I do fell it was a stirring of emotion
in his chest as though he felt more free
to think for himself to question the
nature of his job yeah feel this now
when for years it had never occurred to
him this question would not go
unanswered for long all right well well
I don't know if I'm ready take me up it
only goes down all right don't jump
scares okay
oh well whoa whoa what did I all did I
just say hey easy does it easy does it
uh-huh don't walk on any lines Stanley
walk straight ahead through the large
door that read mind control facility but
what what is that here mean what are you
doing here might escape but but what if
I want to escape it says escape right
here or s kappa s kappa which is french
for four four four nice tits which I
like Gooden I have never heard anyone
say they don't like nice tats Mike file
a fine you know what fine French people
geez they're crazy
alright what are we doing here I like
this I really don't like this what it
the light bulb but why would I never
seen such an to find now whatever this
is [ __ ] the lights rose on an enormous
room packed with television screens what
horrible secret did this place hold
Stanley thought to himself
you have the strip to find out I'm not
neo or anyone
I don't transform like Sailor Moon can i
really be the one who does this I don't
know how can this place be so big that
is totally what a girl say one day
cameras the monitors jumped Wow
their true nature revealed each bore the
number of our employee in the building
Stanley's co-workers the lives of so
many individuals returns on screen and
Stanley one of them eternally monitored
in this place with freedom and nothing
if mind controlling all these people
what about these computers what smell
all the framerate drops geez Wow
fired which number we were like 472 or
something right no mrs. elevator what
this mind control facility it was too
horrible to believe that couldn't be
true and Stanley really been under
someone's control all this time was this
the only reason he was happy with his
boring job those emotions had been
manipulated to accept it blindly well
that's okay hey if you're happy now if
you know he accepted his own life in
someone else's control never
I thought deep sigh thinkable wasn't it
was it even possible had he truly spent
his entire life utterly blind to the
world I guess we're about to find out
salad he was a proof the heart of the
operation controls labeled with emotions
happy or sad or content walking each
aisle working all of it monitored and
commanded from now please and as the
cold reality of his past began to sink
in Stanley decided that this machinery
would never again exert its terrible
power over another human life
now oh he would dismantle the controls
once and for all
all right okay I guess we do it wait
wait we can't we got to stop it somehow
by going in here
mind control idle waiting yeah we get
the final decision huh uh what if we
click on what if we click off what I do
I don't like decisions what if I make
the wrong one chat Tara tell me which
one I should click what's that check off
why what what Gladys
our rising chill of uncertainty yes yes
what's it over yeah I thought it was
what what yes
he had one eye five he had defeated the
Machine unshackled himself from someone
else's command freedom was mere moments
away and yet even as the immense door
slowly opened Stanley reflected on how
many puzzles still lay unsold he's right
we had his coworker gone yeah how had he
been freed from the machines grasps
what's rather mistress did this strange
building hold but as sunlight streamed
into the chamber he realized none of
this mattered to him for it was not
knowledge or even power that he had been
seeking but happiness perhaps his goal
had not been to understand but to let go
no longer would anyone tell him
Whittaker
- OH
whatever life he lives it will be and
that was all Hyde
it was perhaps the only thing worth
knowing
Stanley stepped through the open door
here oh okay
Stanley felt the cool breeze upon his
skin the feeling of liberation the
immense possibility of the new path
before him this was exactly the way
right now that things were meant to
happen and Stanley was happy I long it
was a it was I like that they kept it
the same at dinner a little differently
because it made so made it interesting
wait it's a it's awesome I really I
really dig this this game I don't know
why I'm still here though what the [ __ ]
it just starts on from the beginning
right good workers yeah all right so if
you boys want me to do with the other
endings I think there's five or six
depending on I don't know the last one
had that maybe like if you want to see
the next one or let a comment which one
I should do next what I should do next
and and let's have some fun with this
how people enjoy watching it's the sky
Tacoma with today I'll see you in the
next one